how do i create a thriving environment
for my team well
it's obvious
we have plants everywhere as you can see
this
plant conducts photosynthesis and
provides lots of oxygen for the
environment we have
over here a
[Music]
multi-staged
water filtration so we have
extremely pure water
we we provide water here so this is
incredibly healthy and there's no
particulates or
any plasticizers this is very
good for keeping people hydrated lastly
we provide
a veritable cornucopia of
sustenance as you can see here we are
making
um
taiwanese
braised pork rice and
there's there's food here and
you know we do a good job of sustaining
our employees to keep them very healthy
what makes filtrus different
for for what makes filtrus different
than most companies i would say it's the
people the people are the best thing
about this place excuse me can you can
you move so
the people
especially the employees and the star
employees are are what makes this place
the best
what effect has filters had on my
personal life
it has
um completely overtaken and overrun my
entire life in a good way but you know
it's like 24 7 filtrus and but i love it
so it's like 24 7.
seven days a week
day after day
hour after hour night after night just
filtrates filters and then i just work
and i work and then you know i i sleep
here i'll show you
you know
i
i go to bed right here
and i sleep and
that's about as long as i should be
sleeping and i and i go back to work
how do i empower my employees to have a
voice
um the question should be how do i get
them to shut up it's always like oh
david you know where's the where's the
oat milk for my latte you forgot the oat
milk or hey did you pick up beans at
costco like where's our where's our
beans we don't have beans for the
espresso machine or oh oh it's zippy the
plant's one year anniversary can we buy
a cake for the office
what is some advice i would give new
employees well to the i like to think of
myself as a strong mentor and a coach
what i would say to them is follow your
dreams
don't give up
it's not the size of the
dog in the fight it's the size of the
fight in the dog
and
just
just do it you know
what
makes filtrus a place people want to
work
i thought
that was part of the deal i was
you told me we do this video and
people will want to work here but now
you're asking me that's kind of like
me paying you to have me do your job i
don't i don't really understand
what's going on here